apple did a killer job showing off the
iphone 14 lineup but they conveniently
left out 29 things both good and many
not so good now some of these will
affect which model you should buy and
for some be a good reason to buy an
iphone 13 instead along with ways where
you can actually save some money so make
sure to pay attention as i go through
everything we found scouring their site
and the web let's start out with some
simple ones and then get into the juicy
details that you need to know the first
is that the iphone 14 can now have a mac
like startup chime when turning on
instead of being silent so it's a nice
little confirmation for those that want
it as far as colors they announced only
two new ones for the pro but they didn't
mention that the silver one is also
updated because the glass on the back is
now a true white instead of being
off-white now the new space black color
looks to be very similar to the old
graphite on their website but in reality
it is way darker which i personally like
with that we have new colors for cases
as well as apple's wallets but
unfortunately the white silicon case
that was very popular they are now
completely gone now if you're somebody
that hates camera bumps the iphone 14's
bump is not only larger but it sticks
out way more than ever because of the
new 48 megapixel sensor so these things
are going to wobble like crazy now apple
spent a lot of time on the new cutout
dubbed dynamic island which now looks
super cool because of the new ui
features that they created for it but if
it looks a bit too big for you there is
a reason from an image that apple now
took down from their website you could
see that the visible pill is actually
larger than the cutout that is made for
the camera and the sensors that is
because they are going to anti-alias the
edge of the pixels that they turn off on
the screen to make it look perfect even
if there is a manufacturing defect which
is a good thing because they sometimes
had issues with the original notch not
being perfectly cut out with that unlike
the rumors wi-fi is still exactly the
same from the three-year-old iphone 11
where even budger android phones like
the pixel 6a have way faster wi-fi 6e on
the positive side the new iphones
finally have updated bluetooth 5.3 after
being stuck with 5.0 ever since the
iphone 8 and this is great because of
the new lc3 codec for better audio
quality and lower power usage as well as
better call quality so if you're gonna
pair with the new airpods pro it's gonna
be nice apple said that the new iphone
14 plus has the best battery life in any
iphone ever but that is a bit misleading
because that is only the case for audio
playback rated at 100 hours compared to
95 on the iphone 14 pro max and for
video playback it actually gets beat by
4 hours in general the new iphones are
only one hour better than the 13s and if
you're streaming it is the same as
before which likely means that the
two-year-old x60 5g modem has not been
updated to the new four nanometer x70
which is both 33 faster while saving
battery life and apple didn't mention if
the batteries got any larger but since
they got rid of the sim card you would
think that they would but the 14 pro is
actually the only one that got a small
bump while the pro max actually got a
smaller battery as far as charging they
sell you a 20 watt adapter but the 14s
can actually use up to 27 watts so if
you're gonna buy one get anker's smaller
30 watt which i'll link to in the
description one bummer for me personally
is the e sim on the 14 pro and max they
mentioned that the 14s will be ecm only
but they didn't say anything about the
pro models so i hoped if you're paying
more you will still get that slot but no
it turns out they don't have it either
which is a bummer for those that travel
or they swap sims with an android phone
now if you're like me and you thought
that was for better water resistance
nope it is exactly the same as the
iphone 12 unlike our partner vesey which
are 100 waterproof and will change your
life check this out vessies are made
from dymatex which is a dual climate
knit material that can be submerged and
keep your socks completely dry while at
the same time keep you really cool in
the summer so they are amazing for
year-round use they are extremely
lightweight and comfortable so they
don't feel like they should be
waterproof but they are i love how mine
look and vessy has a bunch of styles to
choose from so i can get some that look
great for work while being ready for any
unpredictable weather they're comfy for
traveling and when i go camping i don't
have to bring my boots with me and when
i did in the past i oftentimes wouldn't
even put my boots on because they're
uncomfortable and then my feet get hot
so i'd wear my regular shoes and then
just deal with my feet getting wet and
soaked and that is something that's just
annoying and in the past now bessies are
the ultimate all-around shoes and you
can use my link in the description with
my code to get 25 off each pair of adult
leslie shoes with free shipping and many
countries so go ahead and check them out
i think you will love them another major
downside with esim that apple didn't
mention is that not everybody will be
able to use it only the seven major
carriers so you have to know about this
before buying with that the pros can
hold up to eight e-sims at once while
for some reason the 14s are limited to
six but of course you can only have two
active at a time now there were rumors
the apple was finally going to upgrade
the ram to 8 gigabyte on the pro models
but they didn't mention ram at all at
the event and we now know why we didn't
get that upgrade to 8 gigabytes of ram
so we're still stuck with 6 just like
the iphone 12s but at the same time the
regular iphone 14s also now have six
gigabytes as far as performance some
people were upset that for the first
time ever apple is reusing an older chip
in a new high-end iphone and only the
pros are getting the new a16 but in
reality it doesn't matter because there
isn't that much of a difference apple
told us how much better it was compared
to the competition but unlike all of the
previous launches they didn't compare it
to the previous chips they were
replacing now the first performance
benchmark showed a slight increase in
single core but practically the same
multi-core performance which was a
bummer but it looks like somebody else
ran it today and the multi-core
performance is up 17 compared to the a15
now one detail that many missed is that
the identifier is different meaning that
it is possible that the 14 pro might
perform the same as the 14 but the 14
pro max actually gets that boost because
it could dissipate heat better we also
just got a graphics performance score
and it is up eight percent compared to
last year but once again this is from
the 14 pro max now i really wish that
apple talked more about thermal
performance and how they compare between
different models on stage what they did
mention is the lower power usage because
of the four nanometer design but unlike
the iphone 14 they didn't say that the
14 pros have improved cooling so there's
still a chance that we might have to
deal with screen dimming like we did on
the 13 pros especially if you'll be
using that 2000 nit brightness for the
outdoors that really will heat up
display that is one thing that we will
have to put to the test once we get all
four of the iphone models that we're
buying so if you want to see that make
sure you're subscribed apple showed off
the full iphone lineup on stage with the
mini being canned but it turns out that
they are still selling the 13 mini and
it is now 100 cheaper so if you still
want a mini it is now 599 bucks but
better yet if you recently bought it
they can actually do a price adjustment
to get you a hundred dollars back so
make sure you take advantage of that
diving into prices more everybody was
happy that apple didn't raise them until
they started looking at the order page
and found out that the 14 pro max is 150
euros more expensive now and the 14 is a
hundred years more expensive while the
13 is still available at the same price
so if you're outside of the us yes these
did get more expensive and even crazier
is that the iphone sc3 went up by 30
euros after the event for no reason at
all just you know maybe inflation money
other stuff same exact phone so if you
wanted to buy one of those hopefully you
already did now apple really marketed
the iphone 14 but in reality it is
actually the brains of the 13 pro but
with things like pro motion disabled it
has five gpu cores in the a15 and it has
some of the cameras as well which also
makes it weird that the 13s aren't
getting the software upgrades for the
photonic engine even though the hardware
fully supports it touching on cameras
now the 48 megapixel camera looks great
on the pros and the upgraded ultrawide
does as well but if it seemed like apple
completely skimmed over the three times
telephoto camera they did so much so
that they didn't even have a spec
graphic for it that is because it is the
same exact one as the 13 pro so won't be
able to keep up with many of the android
phones and the focusing will still miss
at times with that the iphone 14 still
cannot use night mode for portraits so
just like the iphone 12 series portraits
and darker lighting will still look bad
the new action mode they showed off does
look super smooth but apple didn't
mention that the video quality is worse
because of the heavy cropping and it
will not be able to shoot in 4k so keep
that in mind that you are not getting
the best quality so if you're not doing
things like running like crazy you might
not want to use it for those of you that
buy apple care plus they also didn't
mention that it has been upgraded with
unlimited repairs as long as you keep
paying so if you're somebody that breaks
their phone often and you want to keep
your phone for a long time this will be
great one of the most game-changing
features is satellite connectivity for
emergencies now you may have missed it
but apple snuck in that it's free for
two years so at some point it will be
paid now globalstar apple's provider
charges 12 bucks a month for the service
if you're using their spot x which you
have to buy now let me know if you'd be
willing to pay that much once your free
coverage runs out a new feature that
will come alongside the new iphones is
counterfeit airpod detection built into
ios 16 which is great for those of you
guys that want to buy a used set because
some people do buy knockoffs for super
cheap and then resell them for way more
pretending that they're just used ones
or maybe new so that will definitely put
a stop to it and help you know that
you're actually buying genuine ones but
it won't block them out if you want to
buy a pair of knockoffs and save some
money so there you guys go we have a
bunch of things that apple did not
mention let me know down below which
ones really stood out to you or which
ones matter and we will be getting these
new phones and doing a bunch of
comparisons and tests see if the cameras
are that much better than the previous
generations so make sure you guys click
that subscribe button above check out
vesey's down below and check out one of
those two videos as well thank you for
watching this is max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you